yeah don't go for the community you know
helping these people learn how to learn
how to you know be civilized how to read
so I know y'all don't do good things
[ __ ] BTK yeah
hi BTK yeah it's Wednesday yeah
and we're doing the show are we doing it
yeah okay I didn't know if you wanted me
leave that's it I don't give a [ __ ] this
is just normal [ __ ] alright let me give
you guys a heads up during the middle of
the [ __ ] apocalypse see go on Xbox
and go rent guns akimbo yeah you could
probably run another places probably on
another place oh I got it off the Xbox
yep we have one guy in the comment
section say oh I was [ __ ] you know I
[ __ ] loved it so Jenny
it was super fun yeah it's kind of like
it's the same premises running man but
it's more futuristic in terms of like
you know their third live stream in it
yeah a little drones following them and
it's like a criminal organization that
runs this app that captures people
captures criminals and gets them to
fight each other and they make a bunch
of money off of it it's kind of like
kind of like the running man and it's
like the running man had a baby with
John wick three visually it looks like
John wick 3 yeah it's kind of just
classic story talents funny man it's
real funny real violent real gory yeah
coke inspired wait wait sedative yeah we
did good though oh yeah we did like a
full on kind of review of it like a
longer one so that'll be on the mat
nation yeah yeah these heads up on it
yeah cuz we just but like I said we had
they had a good time watching that one
it's uh it kind of totally kind of
reminded me of birds of prey there's a
lot better if that would have beat birds
of prey at the box office easier there
was it's a it's a foreign film so they
did some shenanigans to probably keep it
out of the theaters because they knew it
would [ __ ] kick a [ __ ] out of
Hollywood movie yeah probably yeah at
the box office it would have I think
privative didn't you know probably made
is what John wick made but you could
make you know yeah good money with John
wick yeah
like the best move yeah there was some
kind of some kind of Twitter [ __ ] went
down where some girl was [ __ ] said
some something that was you know said
you know using the n-word and [ __ ] and
the director came in said leave that
girl alone she you driving her to
suicide so then that blew back on him
you know could put political ideology
and [ __ ] which I think all that shit's
[ __ ] you know I don't I don't like
those Twitter let lynch mobs anyway ya
know you don't know who you're talking
to girl might be [ __ ] well probably
that's why I don't get involved in that
[ __ ] I don't defend her attack online I
don't give a [ __ ] and if you guys attack
each other I just like it I just cuz I
don't know you I only care about friends
and family yeah
rest y'all are [ __ ] [ __ ] as you
I'm sitting here during the apocalypse
watch your world fall apart let's see
what happens afterwards to see what
survives I'm hoping that I'm just
watching these celebrities I'm [ __ ]
laugh at these people celebrities are
out now trying to podcast and try to do
[ __ ] they're trying to become
youtubers well what else that's some
funny [ __ ] when you got [ __ ] the
biggest stars in Hollywood do they're
endeavoring to become a damn youtuber I
think it adds Jenny well see you lure
ahead of the [ __ ] curve well many
people were like way ahead of us yeah
but we didn't we didn't start I didn't
take a [ __ ] apocalypse for us to
become youtubers that's but what's funny
is that their shitty youtubers they're
not funny well you aren't funny
I mean the thing about it is that
celebrities you know if they're actors
and stuff like that you know a port
network well yeah that's [ __ ] like it's
not really the same skills yeah you know
what I mean yeah you put some of those
late-night talk show hosts up there
what's his name who's that dude I've
been I've been seeing clips from all of
them Stephen Colbert trying to do [ __ ]
from home he's is the [ __ ] door I
love Stephen Colbert well that's just
his act he not I mean his act is tight
I don't agree with all of his [ __ ]
[ __ ] but
his act is tight but you put in put him
at home he's kind of a boring dude well
like I said nobody's like everybody is
in their [ __ ] house and I wouldn't
get nobody has like all their makeup
crew when everything so everybody kind
of looks like crap and it's like you
know what I made what are you gonna do
yeah what are you gonna do least you're
staying at home it's like going out and
in fact well I'm just saying I'm just
saying you're not I mean I don't I don't
need a whole team of people to and a
bunch of lines of cocaine to make me
entertaining I don't I think I'm just
entertaining the way it is at least you
acknowledge my [ __ ] superpower that's
my [ __ ] superpower
it's like a dick I feel so bad for
people that only just listen does like
on the audio cuz you're missing so many
like facial expressions this was doing
that derma roller my face is all swollen
up I [ __ ] share my eyebrows it a
little bit too short just like a funny
man I almost do like never I said it but
I was gonna [ __ ] shave my eyebrows
off look like a terminator yeah I could
do that now just do it yeah
wait as well should just shave them all
off just so it could look like a [ __ ]
look like look like Robocop now then you
need to get like a Robocop outfit I've
declared that I'm done I'm done bulking
I'm gonna have to lose something I have
to lose some of this fat man this is
what happened I don't know if it was
just because cuz this is what happens
like I said like I [ __ ] it's very very
easy for me to gain weight and I have to
be like really really careful like what
I eat and everything and it does seem
like we'll do good for a little while
because he does most of the cooking you
know I mean I'll miss all the cooking
really it's like you know if I if I eat
I don't have the patience to cook
anything I'll just up like a can of soup
in a bowl and eat it but um so it seems
like we'll do okay for a little while
and then it's just the meals get more
and more fattening like I'm guys on and
I do feel like well I guess especially
now because you know most of the stuff
we had was like shelf-stable stuff and a
lot of that like tends to be fat because
we don't have like any fresh meat or any
fresh vegetables yeah I try to go down
there and they've gone so it's kind of
like you know we just ended up you know
it's like we rented of even like
biscuits gravy and like it's really
heavy stuff and it's like yeah it's been
going on even before this because I was
lifting and I was trying to obvious my
numbers were increasing but I wasn't
able to like recover in enough time so I
started just eating to try to heal that
faster and which it kind of worked but
there's kind of like diminishing returns
of that and then my [ __ ] waistline
gets bigger bigger said then I then I
you know I had J take a [ __ ] video I
mean real quick my shirt off I was
walking around so I could see what my
back looked like and then I was getting
like [ __ ] that thick right through
here and I was going man I gotta lose
some of this [ __ ] fat so this is
looking like a little bloated tick so I
got a six years man to come down come
down I'm gonna come down on my [ __ ]
weight and do a bunch of reps and then I
can go into kind of like caloric
deficits and try to [ __ ] trim some of
it down I just [ __ ] don't want to lose
the muscle that I gave though I'm gonna
work something out yeah I mean you know
there's [ __ ] you can do it's like you
can't it I don't think it's like just a
choice between like I could be bulkier I
can be fat because like some people
aren't there's like another way to do it
I've been you know I've been listening
to some coaches and [ __ ] you know where
they're kind of what do they call it
they could gain tane that's where you
maintaining what you had is there
gaining weight you're gaining you're
gaining muscle and you're maintaining
your weight you know maintaining your
weight and losing fat at the same time
I'm gonna gain tang we're gonna see yeah
we'll see how that I'm gonna see a just
nutrition yeah but well that's good
because like I can't eat like a lot of
heavy food like I said you know not only
will I be like super heavy but it also
kind of makes me like kind of sick like
eating all that really heavy food I feel
better if I eat just like a couple like
little meals a day really good I'm not a
big meal but uh what are you doing soon
making sure everything's all right make
sure I was doing that [ __ ] derma
roller touching your face quit touches
blowing up a little bit we haven't been
anywhere
it's like what's okay the only germs are
now I did go out like on the trail this
morning but I'm like really really
careful about the only thing I touch is
like the fence to get back in our thing
and I always like my hand mmediately
afterwards you could always wait for a
car to come in through the gate they
just run through and I try it like I
said I try to just James like bikes cars
you go under the [ __ ] gate or
whatever
speaking of YouTube's I was just reading
like right before we recorded this I was
just reading an interview with the last
podcast on the left guys and it was kind
of like it's kind of cool because I love
those [ __ ] guys and I feel like I
mean we started doing this show and it
kind of evolved into what we do like but
then I started listening them later I'm
like okay so they kind of have like the
same a similar kind of vibe um you know
where I mean where they talk about
serial killers but they just like make
these horrible dark jokes and you know
kind of [ __ ] on the serial killers which
i think and they kind of have like a
similar thing where it's like we don't
want to like make heroes out of these
people it's like we would just want to
mock them because you know they're
terrible and so I was reading that Nye
said and they said that they started
when they first started the show because
they're like the number two like podcast
like as far as downloads I think they're
does the only thing they're behind is
like one of the NPR like shows which is
number one but their podcast is like
number two and he said they started out
in the basement of a Mexican restaurant
and he's like and there was like every
time it rained like it would flood and
there'd be like kind of sewage in the
bottom of the floor [ __ ] and he's like
we he's like we went to like [ __ ]
Goodwill or something and bought all
these comforters and staple them to the
walls like to soundproof it and it's
like in the three of us were just
sitting as card-table was like [ __ ]
mics and everything and now they're like
a humongous show and they have like two
Studios they have like a studio in New
York I think in a studio in LA and
they're kind of a big deal and
everything but they were talking about
all the different serial killers and one
of them I can't report one but one of
them is fascinated by l ron Hubbard
yeah ontology Wow it sounds like us yeah
so it's like so he talks about him all
the time like he knew like all the [ __ ]
about them and he was like we did a show
about
l ron hubbard he's like you know cuz
everybody shits on like David Miscavige
and everybody like that he's like you
know he's like when we like talk to
people that were Scientologists like
back in the day they loved Elrond yeah
like it seemed like a lot of them didn't
have even though he was kind of a
terrible person also probably he doesn't
he doesn't suck as much as Miscavige but
he did some sideways [ __ ] but he sucked
in other ways but it's like it was just
funny like hearing them talk about it
and they were like we were so hoping
that if we did a show about LRH he's
like I was hoping we'd have like the
squirrel Buster's like if it's like he
knows all the terminology he's like he's
like me and my wife or even like talking
about man we got to watch where we're
going because like the [ __ ]
Scientologists would be out there it was
like it's like it nothing happened I'm
not like squirrel Buster's around like
squirrel Buster's only went after
ex-scientologists that were teaching
Scientology to other people and not
taking it out and taking money and give
it to the church they were squirrel in
the tech is what they call yeah non
Scientologists you know they think we're
all what do they call them [ __ ] ESPYs
yeah so they don't really [ __ ] with us
we're not connected with the church
that's but uh yeah cuz we've done like a
bunch of Elrond RL rh l ron Hubbard he
was you know he founded that whole thing
and by all accounts he was popular in
the church they liked him he would sit
there and put on [ __ ] parties
basically and tell you stories about
what was having on another [ __ ] plan
ants and with that [ __ ] people you know
Alvin yes but he was evidently charming
and entertaining as far as far as you
know in the opinion of the cult members
yeah they liked it I don't think he had
kind of a brutal reputation either no
nothing like Miscavige Miscavige just
[ __ ] mean yeah he's real mean but not
LRH wasn't now certain [ __ ] happened
under his command and when they
infiltrated the [ __ ] FBI yeah which I
people don't know that they did one of
the largest infiltrations of the [ __ ]
government basically of all time they
waited that was my white yeah they were
trying to get in charge get in control
of the FBI just goes to show you how a
group of
[ __ ] dedicated people who are very
loyal to their organization can do do
amazing things and definitions of
amazing well Irish LRH was an
ex-military guy he was you know and he
was a captain of a I think it's some
kind of naval cruiser I don't know was
it was it a pocket destroyer I don't
really remember what it was either
and um during World War two so he ran
the thing kind of like a paramilitary
organization you know he even had his
version of kind of like the Navy SEALs
they were called the Sea Org in the Sea
Org were kind of like Scientology Jedi's
they were [ __ ] they're supposed to be
psychic warriors they wore [ __ ] but
Tom Cruise his operating level is above
he's not in the Sea Org but he's higher
than a Sea Org member so Tom Cruise's is
it like a Scientology Jedi they can read
minds have psionic powers do I believe
it no not those guys I do believe in in
psychic abilities but I don't think they
have them because they're too structured
and their recruitment pool is the kind
of people that join cults and the kind
of people that join cults don't have the
personalities for a wood for psionic
abilities you have to be a free thinker
and you can't be a free thinker in a
cult and be in a cult yeah those are two
mutually exclusive right personalities
you're right
and a lot of things that kind of I think
have to do with psychic abilities that I
don't even like that term because I just
think they're natural abilities in in
animals is not about control and
disciplines about the lack of its giving
up all I'm just surrendering and almost
going into damn a near-death like state
mind stopping stopping the conscious
mind and allowing the unconscious mind
to take over
you get visions you know it's you know
what do they call it
psychokinesis but I think its own from
my experience it's only kind of
recurrent spontaneous psychokinesis
which is not under control
conscious mind so poltergeist activity
but definitely visions and dreaming true
stuff like that but I don't think Sea
Org can do it they're not the right kind
of people they wear them to death well
yeah and you have to be well-rested you
can't be under any kind of physical
stress it's not something that you could
use in combat you know being X infantry
and then having some paranormal events
happen to me you know like NDE and OBE
and poltergeist you couldn't be under
the stress account under the stress of
combat and be psychic at the same time
because the stress account the stress
from combat is very material and
materialistic in the here and now it's
not this ethereal higher you know I mean
it's it's not this Buddhist thing to get
them both at the same time like these
show in the Jedi I don't think it's
possible yeah I get and actually I was
laughing it like when you know the last
podcast on the left when he was talking
about the Scientologists and he's like I
feel like this is paraphrasing but he's
like I feel like the type of people that
it's like they think they have magic
powers like they legit think they have
magic powers and he's like I feel like
this is the kind of people that are all
in one room and say Deborah's gonna walk
through the wall and then she's like hey
did I do it oh I think you actually got
like an engine to the wall this time
actually actually you know I haven't
studied X cult members you know by
listening to their YouTube shows and
[ __ ] and just do it you know sizing them
up some of them are some of the famous
one of the front some of the famous ones
I've actually spoken to online and I'm
not gonna name any names because they're
embarrassing okay
type of person that ends up joining
Scientology and becoming Sea Org which
is their version of the priesthood is
the type of person that would like be
way way into Star Trek conventions it's
that same kata no offense to start no
try to do that I guess no be a little on
Star Trek it's almost kind of like let's
be okay
Star Trek conventions of the 70s in the
80s okay you're talking about when it
wasn't when it wasn't mainstream it was
not like you know they were almost kind
of like Asperger's / kinda what's that
[ __ ] called autism they're kind of like
autistic almost they're not not the kind
of people that can function in a social
situation real well extremely nerdy
extreme extremely nerdy - we're the ones
that the ones that I talked to that
we're still in it because like I said
you know I used to live in Clearwater a
long time ago and I worked at a company
that was owned by them even though it
wasn't you know they didn't like do
Scientology it wasn't a church or
anything like that it was just a
printing company but it was all owned by
Scientologists a lot of people that work
there were Scientologists the weird
thing that I got about them they weren't
they weren't nerdy um it was they join
were they born into it but some of them
were born into it and some of them
joined later but I don't know it's like
it's really hard to like put your finger
on they were just like very very strange
people you could tell that they were
trying to and maybe this is what you
mean when you say like something like
autism but it almost seemed like they
were trying to you know mirror your
reactions and like the way you talked
and stuff like that because they didn't
know because I think they did act yeah
it they do it because they're trying to
like relate to you and stuff but I think
also it's just because they're kind of
like weird and empty inside and they
don't really know how like a human being
acts well the ones that are that's kind
of how they came off to me ones that I
mostly studied were ones that joined
yeah and the kind of person that joins
gonna be very different from the kind of
person that was I was born into as a
person who's born into it has no choice
so I would think kind of like the
qualities of the ones born into it would
be better than somebody who joins
somebody who joined was still they're
still [ __ ] weird though they were
weird because yeah but a person who
joined I probably even weirder because
they're kind of like running from
something and looking for something else
and they're trying to fulfill I've
noticed it's not just Scientology it's
any cult people that I ran into in
Boston who were into joining these
goddamn cults to try to seek what was a
[ __ ] word there's one of my worked
with
for a while and this [ __ ] would join a
cult for a few months and then leave it
and join another one for a few months it
was all this Eastern and Indian pseudo
Indian type you know yoga type [ __ ] what
was the word that he constantly used
trying to find spiritual trying to use
the exact phrase that he used not
enlightenment no transcendence no [ __ ]
[ __ ] so long sir he's to use it over and
over again I'm trying to find my
spirituals I'm gonna and my spiritual
the [ __ ] is this a dude man what's your
patron would you make last week you know
that's not spiritual enough for you you
know that kind of [ __ ] you know we
talking about it's just some people have
this driving instinct in them to be
involved in some kind of a religion that
tells them some kind of truth which I
don't it's an alien concept to me
because me me too
you know I kind of grew up around
religions and that's not that's not how
it's not what they're like it's not a
religion religion is just aren't like
that but there are some people who are
think that they are and I don't know if
that person came from a religious family
or maybe a family that had no religion
and they felt that well if I gain a
religion I'll feel better about life
yeah because I do think I'm not like
them we do i I'm not [ __ ] on people
that are like looking for a meaning in
life or something like that but the
thing about people that join cults it's
like they seem to think that there's
like one answer that you know like solve
everything or like solve other problems
that are it will make me happy it'll do
this now there's just no such thing it's
like really you just have to find
meaning in you know stuff that you love
stuff that you like to do it's there's
no one answer out there that's like the
right thing for everybody yeah I
remember trying to complete my spiritual
journey or some [ __ ] like that
everything was at some kind of spiritual
journey and it was just yeah my boss
I've known a couple boss innate here -
here - God talk like that she would just
like look at me like this matter of fact
he's crazy you know
in doric you know because there's an
element of an element of scam and all
that well yeah and I was in a company
that was very heavily heavy in direct
sales and even though you have a good
product there's a certain way you have
to sell things directly there's an
element of scam in everything yeah you
know all businesses have an element of
scam in it and what we were doing was so
similar to what say like a religious
cults were doing it you know some people
have there's a lot of similarities a lot
of similarity between what happens in
the corporate world and what happens in
religious you know it's all PR the sales
sales techniques high-pressure sales
pitches yeah that's what you're doing so
I mean we actually knew people that
would leave the company and go into the
religion sector yeah and go do that the
religion sector and go make money in the
religion sector for a while yeah I mean
and it's in we were selling a physical
object oh yeah they were selling a
notional object of a [ __ ] imaginary
object something they could never prove
yeah yeah some [ __ ] out of [ __ ] yoga
you know or some Indian thing or some
[ __ ] yes so you need like you know
that much more yes damn on top yeah yeah
it's at least if you're selling somebody
I mean everything it's basically you're
just trying to you know separate people
from their money basically basic but at
least with something like when you're
selling a product product like you sell
vacuum cleaners or you're selling
magazines yourself Amway at least
release getting something for your money
right even though it might not be what
you wanted or right now because but you
know the thing about religion is you
know in cults and things like that
they're trying to sell you something
that you know you can't probably doesn't
exist and it's like not right you know
what I mean so you say I'm sit in a
lotus position or you haven't say about
two homes and my [ __ ] saffron colored
[ __ ] robe and [ __ ] cetera the airport
ambery you make the baby are well they
can get beyond certain physical
boundaries where you don't have to
protect a [ __ ] just give the [ __ ]
everybody but it belongs to everybody
and that's [ __ ] what they're doing I
can't believe that women it'd be like oh
yeah yeah it does belong to everybody
yeah share it's like you know Thank You
sheriff you just walk up some woman lift
your leg share yeah it's like no that
was [ __ ] you just keeping this there
beyond get beyond your selfishness
that's right me that is the biggest load
of horseshit ever the sex has always
wants sex and money and really that the
root of all those well yeah of course
but it's what's strange about
Scientology is that sex wasn't the only
one I didn't think of this no one that
it didn't take advantage
well evident not officially they were
not taking advantage of women didn't
seem like I mean you know it's hard for
me to believe that there wasn't some of
that [ __ ] going on but it's actually
uptight yeah it definitely does seem
like the only cult that I can think of
that didn't have like a weird sexual
component yeah like even that one dude
that dude is like a fake Indian fake
here remember that where he was made on
the surface everything looked asexual
that sex was something that she didn't
do but he was actually molesting all the
guys yeah that's right remember that
yeah that's right then they were like
honest about yeah it was weird he kind
of talked me into that I'm not gay he
talked me into it you know sorry man
you're gay
well no I mean you know just like well
how did you talk about into that I did
Joe exotic talked his husbands into like
have it they were both sure it was not
he didn't talk a minute that [ __ ] has
met it was that's what I was gonna say
it is I'm gonna do math yeah they'll do
anything to get it like I said a lot of
a lot of drug addicts and stuff like
that will do that yeah you know what I
mean it's just a job yeah that's how
they so let's like do a porn it's like
you don't I mean it I like what I
couldn't do it man you yeah you'd have
you have to you have to be a certain
time you have to be a certain kind of
person you really have to need that meth
yeah and you know I've never wanted
anything bad you know what I mean yeah
speaking of Scientology somebody just a
couple minutes ago some
sent me a message they were commenting
on our trilogy of terror review and I
actually didn't know this but they said
Karen black was a Scientologist
yeah and the reason that she she had a
she died of cancer and she never went to
get it treated because Scientologists
think they can treat everything well no
some people just let it go I mean your
grandmother didn't go no she did she did
that she said but then she said [ __ ] it
well after because after they did the
surgery and after they did everything
then they were kind of like oh well we
didn't get it all and she was hasn't
been mentioned in anything recent with
the church yeah I know well which I mean
it's been a while since she died so
maybe why that's maybe that's why I
never heard because like I hadn't
thought I knew Blake most of the famous
Scientologists but I had never heard her
she must have been what they call public
yes a lot of the celebrities um yeah
they just take the courses and they're
not like see they're not in they're not
like living in the it alone right living
with them and they're not you know then
he just give them money you know there's
just public Scientology which their that
the public Scientologist is not the same
as somebody who's in to see you yeah the
experience is completely yeah or
somebody who's in staff you know that
they really meant they really
micromanage them public they don't they
just built them for money if you want to
like read something really horrifying
here's another book recommendation for
you read beyond belief by Jenna
Miscavige that's his niece she was
raised in it and it is horrifying yeah
horrifying so yeah that's my book
recommendation for it if you want to
cheer yourself up there's a real good
YouTube channel written it's kind it's
managed by somebody who left it sure
she's real high rank and I've forgotten
my name is drawing a blank right now
anyway they have a show on YouTube
called surviving Scientology yeah yeah
and they have some interviews with like
old classic members that new l ron
Hubbard and what it was like and how
[ __ ] up his teeth were and [ __ ] like
that you know man his mouth always
bothered ya English and really the story
I like the stories of the old church
what Elrod was still alive yeah because
there was some of those stories were
bizarre you know they're living in
barracks and pouring drinks and [ __ ]
it's just you know pretty interesting of
how it was like and then the secret
compounds that were built out in the
desert to protect the [ __ ] holy
script on [ __ ] titanium plates you
know and the guys that guarded out in
the middle of the desert commit suicide
because there's nothing to do out there
they got guns and [ __ ]
crazy yeah it's like a prison out in the
middle of the desert with like five guys
in it
you should be able to see baby cookie
don't you know that you are a pokey star
oh yeah yeah that's kind of a thing that
we always like whenever we hear a song
we try to like sing part of the song but
like put her name in it yeah I don't
know she likes it or not she just kind
of looks at us like being a porn star
but she's like whatever Mommy and Daddy
you guys are so weird really well she
had to talk about I don't think so look
at her sticking her butt in the camera
oh yeah she likes to chew on wood for
some reason I buy our two sticks all the
time and it doesn't matter now she was a
chew on random [ __ ] she just wants the
chew on random stuff all right so I have
a rest of the good rest of the Wednesday
what rest of Wednesday what the [ __ ] am
I talking about I don't know
and we will talk to you guys again
tomorrow